[Música]
graña advierte a los civiles que viven
en el donbass que abandonen la zona
luego de que moscú reforzará su
estrategia en esta región del este
ucraniano mientras tanto se acumula la
evidencia de presuntos crímenes de
guerra en los lugares que abandona el
ejército de kremlin
en la recta final de la primera vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales en
francia las encuestas siguen mostrando
una ventaja cada vez más estrecha entre
el presidente y candidato emanuel macrón
y la ultraderechista marine lepén apenas
tres puntos y medio de margen según ifop
al menos cinco muertos es el saldo que
dejan días de protestas en perú las
movilizaciones lideradas por los
transportistas han evolucionado en un
rechazo ante el presidente pedro
castillo a quien acusan de incumplir sus
promesas electorales
actualizamos las noticias en la pantalla
de france 24 gracias por permanecer con
nosotros yo soy copiarles el alcalde de
la ciudad estratégica de mariupol elevó
a más de 5000 las cifras de fallecidos
civiles tras la arremetida rusa a medida
que se recolecta más información tras el
retiro de las tropas de vladimir putin
las autoridades ucranianas piden a la
población que abandonen la región del
donbass y es que según eeuu el kremlin
completó la retirada del este de su
ejército de la región de kiev la capital
y de chernin hiv en el norte y está
enfocando sus esfuerzos allí en el este
del territorio el pentágono aseguró que
puede que ucrania gane la guerra
y en cuanto a tu pregunta sobre si
podemos ganar o si hemos renunciado a
que ganen o si esto significa que no
puedan ganar porque pensamos que va a
durar mucho tiempo la respuesta es
absolutamente no por supuesto que se
puede ganar si miras lo que han sido
capaces de hacer hasta ahora el señor
putin ha logrado exactamente cero de sus
objetivos estratégicos dentro de ucrania
no ha tomado kiev no derrocó al gobierno
lo eliminó ucrania como un estado
nacional y realmente solo está tomando
el control de un pequeño número de
centros de población y ni siquiera eran
los que realmente perseguidos
y en medio de la atención mundial de
eeuu se acercan a cuba en la habana se
celebra la tercera conferencia agrícola
a pesar de las sanciones económicas que
washington aplica a cuba ambas naciones
llevan a cabo un intercambio en ese
sector estimado en 250 millones de
dólares
un acercamiento en tiempos de escasez en
medio del grave desabastecimiento de
productos de primera necesidad en cuba'
una representación de productores
agrícolas estadounidenses visitó la isla
para impulsar la cooperación en el
sector agrario
la agricultura representa a uno de los
más importantes vínculos que suponen
nuestras relaciones económicas y
políticas
pero claramente podemos hacer mucho más
y necesitamos hacer mucho más en el
encuentro se identificaron las sanciones
económicas de washington a la habana
como uno de los principales obstáculos
para el desarrollo de los intercambios
el actual embargo bloqueo limite el
comercio de manera significativa
significa pues según la asociación
nacional de departamentos estatales de
agricultura estadounidense el
intercambio agrícola mutuo rondaría en
los mil millones de dólares de no
existir las medidas contra la mayor de
las antillas reconocemos el tradicional
interés del sector agrícola estado
estadounidense que ha estado presente en
el aprovechamiento
oportunidades de participar en la
producción de alimentos en la reunión se
lee como uno de los recientes gestos de
distensión del gobierno de los eeuu
lleva a cabo con la habana este
miércoles se conoció además que la
embajada de washington en cuba reanudará
los servicios de visados para migrantes
a partir del mes de mayo este
acercamiento tiene lugar en medio de las
tensiones mundiales entre el país del
norte y uno de los mayores aliados del
gobierno cubano hablamos ahora de las
elecciones francesas que se celebran
este domingo la extrema derecha llega
con fuerza a esta cita con dos
representantes marine lepén de
agrupación nacional y el ex hemos de
reconquista los candidatos han apelado a
propuestas populistas pero se han
intentado distanciar el uno del otro
a pesar de las fracturas la extrema
derecha ha logrado abrirse un espacio
considerable en el electorado francés la
pugna es entre la candidata de la
agrupación nacional marine le pen y el
representante de reconquista edic se me
llega con un voto dividido
porque entre ambos se pueden estar
contrarrestando y bueno el epen por un
lado sigue por delante en lo que sería
el voto obrero el voto de la clase
trabajadora mientras que ese muro está
haciendo más hincapié en lo que es la
clase acomodada y los electores de ese
género con el antiguo legalismo dependen
alrededor del 22 por ciento de los votos
mientras que se mojó un 85 entre los dos
superan el 27 por ciento de los votos
que obtendría el actual mandatario
enmanuel macrón en primera vuelta según
la encuesta ipsos ofra desencantados
inconformes con el gobierno de macrón
patriotas y antisistemas son algunos de
los electores que se decantan por la
extrema derecha pero su discurso también
ha calado en parte de la juventud
principalmente porque ha salido a entre
otras entre otras cosas utilizadas muy
bien las redes sociales cosas la
izquierda no se ha sabido adaptar a ello
además de tener la juventud que tiene
ciertos problemas
que la derecha o la extrema derecha en
este caso le ofrecen soluciones
simplistas las banderas compartidas
entre los dos candidatos son muchas la
anterior acción el orden la seguridad la
protección de los valores tradicionales
entre otras
pero aún así intentan distanciarse se
move de 63 años se vendía como la
novedad con una campaña marcada por
apelar a la emotividad y exacerbando el
discurso de la extrema derecha sobre
todo en temas de migración proponiendo
un ministerio encargado de devolver a
miles de personas a su país
somos los únicos herederos de la derecha
que amamos a francia a la gente al
trabajo al orden ya la identidad
depp en una cara conocida ha intentado
suavizar su imagen haciendo una campaña
más cercana a la gente concentrándose en
problemáticas concretas
contra el bloque de las élites contra la
oligarquía que encarna emanuel ma con
ésta el pueblo y el pueblo es más
numeroso que la casta a pesar de que
para muchos el discurso del epen estaba
desgastado las encuestas indican que se
enfrentaría a su antiguo rival en manual
macrón en una segunda vuelta
pero al menos cinco personas han muerto
en medio de las protestas que comenzaron
como un rechazo por parte de los
transportistas a los precios de
combustible y que han evolucionado en un
movimiento de rechazo contra el
presidente pedro castillo más temprano
paula taba la pineda politóloga nos
explicaba el momento crítico de castillo
si efectivamente este es el momento más
crítico para el presidente castillo por
un lado porque son las movilizaciones
más grandes a las que se está
enfrentando hasta ahora había habido
movilizaciones incluso desde los
primeros días de su gestión pidiendo su
salida pero mucho más ideologizada de
determinados sectores de la derecha este
son los movimientos más grandes y además
esto tiene que tener en consideración
que varias de las regiones están
movilizadas ya estamos hablando de 15
por lo menos de las 25 regiones del país
son regiones en las que el presidente
castillo tuvo alto nivel de votación de
hecho la región de la que es originaria
su parte es el partido político por el
que gobierna es un de las naciones donde
se ha puesto el foco del conflicto y
donde hay al menos tres de los
fallecidos estamos hablando de la
pérdida de legitimidad de un presidente
que se hizo llamar desde el inicio el
presidente del pueblo y del gobierno del
pueblo y que parece haber perdido a ese
pueblo del todo la organización
panamericana de la salud advirtió que la
sub variante de omicron ve a punto 2 del
comic 19 está a punto de provocar una
nueva ola de contagios en el continente
americano
la sub variante ba2 de omicron ya ha
sido detectada en 87 de las secuencias
reportadas en américa del sur según la
organización panamericana de la salud
quien agregó que esta situación se
esperaba luego de ver un repunte en
europa y en el este de asia bea 2 ya es
dominante en eeuu mientras que en canadá
actualmente las hospitalizaciones
aumentaron un 10% y los casos un tercio
en comparación con la semana del 20 al
26 de marzo
en todo el caribe 15 países y
territorios también experimentaron un
aumento en las nuevas infecciones los
informes de muertes también aumentaron
en toda la región
la hoy bs informó que la vacunación ha
sido un aspecto decisivo en el avance de
esta su variante alertó que pese a las
altas tasas en la región más de 240
millones de personas no han recibido ni
una sola dosis la organización también
responsabiliza el levantamiento
prematuro de los protocolos contra el
kobe 19
a medida que se relajaron las
restricciones de viaje el número de
casos aumentó en lugares que dependen
del turismo especialmente en partes de
américa del norte y el caribe
para luchar contra la aparición de
nuevas variantes la opep se urgió a las
autoridades de los países a mantener
fácil acceso a las pruebas de detección
a pesar del avance de la variante vea
dos los casos semanales de kobe 19 en la
región de las américas han disminuido
menos en américa del norte que desde
france24
[Música]